[Aplausos]
[Música]
y si te dijera que el nuevo enemigo de
los talibanes dentro de afganistán son
los salafistas habéis oído bien hablamos
de un enfrentamiento religioso en toda
regla y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
en este momento pero qué clase de lucha
religiosa pueden tener si profesan la
misma fe tanto los talibanes como los
salafistas creen en el islam sunita y
ambos son extremistas qué clase de
diferencia religiosa pueden tener pues
muchas
[Música]
veréis dentro del islam hay cuatro
escuelas jurídicas distintas los
talibanes siguen a la escuela hanafy que
no tiene nada que ver con la sala pista
y grace pero en que se diferencian pues
los talibanes permiten interpretar los
textos sagrados usando la razón y la
opinión y si ya sé qué razón y opinión y
talibanes parecen una contradicción pero
es que los salafistas son aún más
radicales porque dicen que los textos
sagrados no se pueden interpretar ni en
la última coma por supuesto durante la
guerra de afganistán tanto talibanes
como salafistas tuvieron ciertas
alianzas sobre todo con ese grupo
terrorista de confesión salafista que
todos conocemos al qaeda sin embargo con
eeuu fuera del tablero han vuelto los
enfrentamientos no obstante no creáis
que hablamos de una guerra abierta la
realidad es que los salafistas son una
minoría en afganistán en parte gracias a
la opresión de los talibanes ojo esto no
significa que afganistán sea ningún
paraíso de la tolerancia y los derechos
humanos todo lo contrario
[Música]
como vamos a ver en este vídeo hay
muchas formas de radicalismo islámico y
todas ellas pueden ser violentas y
peligrosas pero hoy vamos a centrarnos
en los salafistas y diréis pero porque
nos interesan tanto los salafistas pues
porque el salafismo es una de las ramas
del islám de más rápido crecimiento los
artistas han ido expandiéndose por el
mundo desde hace décadas y diréis porque
pues porque cuentan con el músculo
financiero para hacerlo de quien estamos
hablando pues nada más y nada menos que
de un viejo conocido aquí en visual
político arabia saudita pero no creáis
que hablamos sólo de mezquitas radicales
en occidente el salafismo también se
está expandiendo por todo el mundo
musulmán muchos países musulmanes
moderados están sucumbiendo a los
encantos del radicalismo salafista así
que las preguntas que hoy nos hacemos
son porque debemos preocuparnos por el
salafismo qué impacto puede tener esto
en nuestras vidas y por qué el salafismo
es tan atractivo en países musulmanes
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes
[Música]
y
antes quiero recordaros que si os gusta
visual política ahora podéis apoyar
activamente este proyecto y diréis como
pues suscribiéndose al patrón de visual
política además de permitir que este
proyecto pueda seguir adelante si es
único nuestro patrón recibiréis nuestra
newsletter las claves de la semana donde
tocamos muchos más temas que no nos da
tiempo a cubrir en forma de vídeo pero
es que además a partir del nivel 3
recibiréis nuestro merchandising
exclusivo merchandising como éste que
nunca nunca nunca estará a la venta
tenéis todos los enlaces en la
descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
doctor sala and mystery hat
todos asociamos salafismo con arabia
saudita sin embargo el salafismo nace en
la actual irak en el siglo 19 la palabra
salafismo viene de salad que es como se
llamaba a los estudiosos del islam tras
la muerte de mahoma y los salafistas
eran estudiosos que defendían que los
textos sagrados no se pueden interpretar
se tienen que aplicar a rajatabla y os
preguntaréis pero qué tiene que ver el
salafismo con arabia saudita pues todo
viene del siglo 18 cuando un clérigo que
se llamaba al wahhab convirtió al jefe
tribal más importante de la zona lo
único que en vez de llamarlo salafismo
en un acto de humildad lo llamo
wahabismo porque por lo visto pues este
hombre quería ser famoso y el resto es
historia
[Música]
en los años 30 del siglo 20 arabia
saudita descubrió que tenían tubo de
dinosaurio para dar y vender así que de
repente un montón de inmigrantes de
otros países musulmanes emigraron para
trabajar en los campos de petróleo
saudíes y ya sabéis el resto de la
historia entre barril de petróleo y
oraciones diarias puede ser terminaron
convirtiendo al salafismo y lo trajeron
de vuelta cuando volvían a sus países de
origen
pero no sólo eso que creéis que hacen
todos esos saudíes con todo el dinero
que ganan con el petróleo pues aquí es
donde llega la gran brecha saudí de la
que ya os hemos hablado varias veces
aquí en visual político veréis la casa
real saudí usa prácticamente todo el
dinero para vivir a todo tren y
comprarse en mansiones y coches de lujo
sí vale es cierto que mantienen ciertas
convenciones religiosas pero se olvidan
de toda la parte del salafismo que dice
que hay que ser austero y modesto pero
luego tenemos a los salafistas truck los
auténticos eso es que por muy ricos que
sean nunca se pondrán un traje de
giorgio armani porque va en contra de
los textos sagrados estos artistas usan
su dinero para expandir su palabra por
todo el mundo y claro algunos se
preguntarán pero y qué hay de malo en
que se expande una religión si todas lo
hacen pues si tenéis razón el problema
es que dentro del salafismo también hay
corrientes que predican la violencia si
amigos de visual político estamos
hablando del yihadismo
[Música]
sin embargo esperad un momento porque la
jihad es un término bastante desconocido
en occidente en realidad hay dos niveles
de yihad por un lado tenemos la hija
menor que consiste en la lucha contra el
infiel en este caso cualquiera que no
practique el salafismo y en la mayor
parte de los casos por lucha entendemos
lucha violenta pero luego existe la
yihad mayor la yihad mayor consiste en
la lucha interna contra el mayor infiel
que puede haber que es uno mismo la
lucha interna por controlar nuestros
propios deseos y ser fieles al corán
dicho de otra forma muchas veces podemos
escuchar a un clérigo musulmán hablar de
yihad y eso no significa necesariamente
que esté hablando de matar infieles
hecha esta aclaración hay algo que
muchos estaréis preguntando ahora cómo
es posible que una religión tan radical
se expanda tan rápidamente pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
la expansión del salafismo versión mal
no es ninguna sorpresa que la religión
se utiliza como una arma política y esto
se lleva haciendo durante toda la
historia así que cuando todo áfrica del
norte se independizó de sus
colonizadores europeos los salafistas
pensaron que tenían una oportunidad de
crecimiento y diréis les salió bien pues
la respuesta es que no mal salió fatal
por ejemplo cuando argelia estaba en
guerra con francia los salafistas
tuvieron cierto momento de gloria pero
tan pronto como argelia se independizó
los partidos o las listas quedaron
marginados durante la guerra entre india
y pakistán tanto árabe saudita como
qatar financiaron a grupos terroristas a
la pista esperó a duras penas lograron
poder político real y en afganistán
tenemos más o menos lo mismo fue un
auténtico fracaso
primero los comunistas frenaron
cualquier movimiento religioso pero
después los talibanes frenaron a los
salafistas durante la última guerra de
afganistán éstos salafistas habrían
logrado cierta presencia en este caso su
principal valedor era el estado islámico
en la provincia de jorasán pero en
cuanto a los talibanes se han hecho con
todo el poder del país los salafistas
han sido una de las primeras víctimas
atentos los talibán se enfrentan al y
escape su rival más serio en afganistán
y la misma historia la tenemos con las
primaveras árabes ni en túnez ni en
egipto han logrado expandirse sí por
supuesto en todos estos países hay algún
partido político salafista pero en túnez
no ganan las elecciones en egipto si es
que no hay elecciones que ganar sin
embargo hay una zona donde el salafismo
sí que está ganando terreno de qué
países hablamos pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
como extender una religión
vale creo que ya nos ha quedado claro a
todos que el régimen saudita quiere
expandir el salafismo la pregunta es por
qué no se enfrenta a la casa real saudí
a fin de cuentas eeuu tiene herramientas
más que suficientes para presionarles y
aquí es donde viene el gran lote twist
de esta historia de verdad es el régimen
saudí quien financia las mezquitas a
racistas
[Música]
pues sí y a la vez no arabia saudita
dona dinero a ongs islámicas como por
ejemplo la liga del mundo islámico sobre
el papel esto es ayuda humanitaria sin
más pero muchos de los encargados de
estas ongs desvían dinero a la causa
yihadista sin embargo buena parte de la
financiación del salafismo internacional
viene de la sociedad civil habéis oído
bien buena parte de la financiación de
las mezquitas salafistas fuera de arabia
saudita viene del sector privado viene
de personas privadas es decir de estos
salafistas true que no tienen nada que
ver con la casa real saudí
hablamos de banqueros empresarios
inmobiliarios y funcionarios con
salarios altísimos en lugar de utilizar
su dinero para comprarse mansiones en
marbella lo utilizan para construir
mezquitas en chechenia y diréis seguro
que están compinchados con el régimen
saudí puedo cierto es que no como
decíamos al principio estos salafistas
trump odian a la casa real saudí porque
consideran que se han vendido a las
comodidades de los infieles no me creéis
pues os voy a dar una muestra a nivel
político como ya sabéis arabia saudita y
qatar se llevan a matar eso es de
primero de visual político sin embargo
los salafistas true no entienden de
fronteras tanto qataríes como saudíes
van de la mano en lo que ha construido
mezquitas se refiere la religión está
muy por encima de los intereses de las
distintas casas reales ahora es así las
cosas como son arabia saudita no ha
hecho prácticamente nada por evitar
estos movimientos pero eso es otra
historia a estas alturas ya estaréis
ansiosos de saber dónde ha conseguido
triunfar el salafismo pues preparadas
las maletas porque nos vamos a chechenia
[Música]
dicen ya es una región de rusia famosa
por sus campos de concentración de
homosexuales durante siglos los
chechenos profesaban el islam sufí y
diréis pero como ha podido entrar el
salafismo por estas zonas pues por tres
simples razones guerra pobreza y
exclusión social
y ya se lo que se estaría preguntando
pero qué guerra ha tenido tenia pues una
muy grande contra la propia madre roshia
chechenia declaró unilateralmente la
independencia y en moscú les mandaron al
ejército esta fue la llamada primera
guerra ruso chechena que acabó con la
vida de más de 40 mil personas en un
territorio de poco más de un millón de
habitantes fue un duro golpe y después
de la represión rusia aisló
económicamente a techo ni a graso error
en el dinero de rusia a chechenia no les
quedó más remedio que aceptar dinero de
arabia saudita qatar y kuwait y así es
como llegaron las primeras mezquitas
salafistas
[Música]
pensadlo bien no solo hablamos de una
mezquita dónde vas a rezar sin más
hablamos de escuelas donde educan a los
niños gratis o por precios irrisorios
entre lección de matemáticas y lección
de geografía te meten un poquito de
salafismo es decir el salafismo es mucho
más que una religión también ofrece
cierta cobertura social y esto es
especialmente atractivo en lugares
devastados por la guerra y todo esto
explica que años más tarde cuando
estalló la segunda guerra rusos de chena
los salafistas terminaron por establecer
el emirato del cáucaso este emirato
acabó por disolverse después de que el
dinero del yihadismo internacional fuera
todo el para el estado islámico es más
incluso muchos chechenos terminaron
marchándose a combatir a siria sin
embargo ahora el salafismo en chechenia
está en horas bajas y diréis porque pues
gracias en buena medida a nuestro buen
amigo putting y su mejor amigo ramzán
kadyrov del que ya hemos hablado alguna
vez aquí en visual politics
[Música]
kadírov es el señor de la guerra que
gobierna entretenía con el apoyo de
vladimir putin básicamente putin le dijo
en su día a kadyrov a ver mira kadyrov
comió benach ataca a las barrabasadas
que quieras dentro de tu territorio
ahora eso sí no quiero ver ni un solo
terrorista por el resto de rusia y como
ve un terrorista por aquí es que se te
calpe y las cosas como son kadírov solo
ha tomado en serio muy pero muy en serio
de hecho hasta tiene un mensaje para
todos esos chechenos que se han ido a
combatir al estado islámico la udo heart
jaula y se otean cyrus ya la ocu divino
pcia amelia el codo ya ley y creedme os
voy a dar un consejo si cadillac te dice
que se encargará personalmente de
aniquilar te hazle caso la historia de
este hombre es para echarse a temblar
por supuesto que chechenia sigue siendo
un lugar extremadamente pobre y algunas
zonas mantienen sus mezquitas pero no
está claro por cuánto tiempo van a
seguir sin embargo chechenia no es el
único territorio donde el salafismo se
ha expandido donde más diríais que ha
tenido éxito como muchos habréis
adivinado hablamos de asia central es
decir la tierra de los instantes más
concretamente en tayikistán
instant
en estos dos países casi el 30% de la
población es partidaria del salafismo
esto es más de 4 millones y medio de
personas y diréis pero son todos
yihadistas y violentos pues no
necesariamente el movimiento islámico de
uzbekistán si practica la llamada yihad
menor pero principalmente el salafismo
en esta zona tiene un nombre un nombre
por cierto impronunciable es de ut
tahrir sub 10 prof hablamos de un
partido político que nació en los años
90 y diréis pero porque tienen tantos
partidarios pues principalmente por una
razón su discurso contra la corrupción
tal cual como louis los salafistas
parecen ser lo suficientemente outsiders
como para tomarse en serio su retórica
anti corrupción a partir de eso el resto
del discurso religioso entra mucho mejor
pero ahora la pregunta que todos estáis
haciendo a no ser que seas el propio
ratnam kadyrov es es necesario combatir
la expansión del salafismo hasta qué
punto hablamos de un problema real pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
combatir terror o combatir creencias
en efecto mis queridos amigos de visual
política el mundo se ha unido para
luchar contra el salafismo yihadista es
decir contra los terroristas para que os
hagáis una idea de la magnitud del
problema solo hay que ver los datos
entre el año 2002 y el año 2014 los
principales grupos salafistas yihadistas
es decir el estado islámico y su filial
en nigeria boko haram y al shaab
acabaron con algo más de 54 mil vidas
casi todas estas víctimas no son de
países occidentales sino del propio
mundo musulmán y diréis pero cómo es
esto posible pues porque como ya hemos
dicho antes para un salafista-yihadista
un infiel es todo aquel que no sea
salafista y si eso incluye a todos los
demás musulmanes y lo mismo ocurre en
occidente no hace falta que os recuerde
la larga lista de atentados que hemos
sufrido en toda europa y es que si en
toda europa contamos con un montón de
mezquitas radicales queréis un ejemplo
os doy un ejemplo
la gran mezquita de bruselas y su
vínculo con el salafismo la mezquita más
grande de bruselas está financiada por
arabia saudi un régimen salafista los
líderes se han disociado del terrorismo
pero no están contando todo y esto es lo
que ocurre en bélgica sabéis lo que han
hecho los franceses sus fuerzas de
seguridad se han infiltrado en los
oficios de las mezquitas y han
descubierto cuántos clérigos se emplean
discursos radicales de hecho entre 2012
y 2015 expulsaron a nada menos que 52
clérigos del país por estas razones
vale el terrorismo yihadista se combate
y la radicalización también pero y qué
pasa con el salafismo como doctrina
religiosa pues en estos momentos podemos
decir que el mundo musulmán vive en su
propia batalla cultural habéis oído bien
el salafismo no es la única doctrina
islámica que se intenta expandir hay
muchos grupos en todo el mundo que se
dedican a luchar contra el salafismo
desmintiendo su discurso y sus acciones
uno de ellos está en indonesia y se
llama nahda tool un lama se calcula que
tienen entre 40 y 90 millones de rectos
sólo en indonesia y ojo porque indonesia
es el país con la mayor población
musulmana de todo el mundo ahora bien
eso no significa que todas estas
organizaciones no sean radicales algunos
de ellos incluso plantean problemas para
los gobiernos de los países donde actúan
mientras tanto la única opción que
parece viable a día de hoy es combatir
el terrorismo es decir dejar la religión
a un lado y centrarse en las células
terroristas y por el momento la acción
coordinada entre países está funcionando
relativamente bien desde el año 2014 los
atentados terroristas se han reducido en
un 60% en todo el mundo y esto son
buenas noticias
pero ahora turno para vosotros queréis
que esto es suficiente deberíamos
presionar más arabia saudita para que
evite la financiación de grupos
yihadistas podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones y
por supuesto recordad que podéis
colaborar activamente con este proyecto
pasando a formar parte de nuestra
comunidad en patria si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]